[Musik]
mit etwas klappt bekommen beim ein video
auf jeden fall gibt es heute nach langer
zeit mal ein video mit dem ich auf der
einen seite fehlen von euch also ich
würde so ab und zu über gefragt hey kann
es mal wieder so auch roths etwas
bezogenes machen und ich bekomme in
letzter zeit wirklich sehr sehr oft zu
lesen
alex du drückst sich immer so lange aus
versucht doch einfach mal irgendwas
kürzer auszudrücken und ja da habe ich
mir gedacht komm du machst einfach mal
dieses video und wenn es die größten
fehler von mädchen auf what's it also es
wissen jungs mädchen video ich habe da
glaube ich früher schon mal ein video zu
gemacht also ähnlich halt das ging
irgendwie habe ich dazu noch kein video
gemacht ich bin da irgendwie drauf
gekommen und habe mir so gedacht hey da
brauchst du gar nicht viel drum rum
überlegen sondern ich zähle jetzt
einfach mal so viele punkte auf wie mir
dazu einfallen
in kürzester zeit und dann merkt immer
dass ich halt auch also mein gehirn kann
auch schnell arbeiten okay also die
größten fehler von mädchen auf holz-
oder generell halt fehler von mädchen
rotz etwas schreiben angeht was generell
web angeht weil whatsapp ist ja wirklich
eine sache die es präsent in jeder
lebenslage in jeder situation und so
weiter ganz wichtig vorneweg noch ich
will niemanden damit angreifen oder so
es sind einfach nur sachen die
vielleicht eigentlich so ich sag mal so
von den sachen betreffen euch vielleicht
jetzt zwei drei sachen und das sind
sachen die sind vielleicht nicht so cool
so ihr müsst jetzt natürlich abstellen
aber jungs also viele jungs würde ich
mal schätzen finden das nicht gut
das hat den sache einfach so es geht
übrigens darum dass ein mädchen und ein
junge schreibt ja vielleicht kann es
auch darum gehen das mädchen einfach
freundin sucht kann auch passen
okay wir fangen mit sachen war einst das
ist eigentlich ziemlich easy und zwar
schreibt ein mädchen mit irgendeiner
anderen person sei es jetzt ein junge
oder eine freundin die sie sucht und du
als mädchen max eigentlich besteht nicht
so interesse es können keine antwort
zurück du schreibst dann aber dennoch
immer ein fragezeichen und auch umfragen
zeigen dass nicht gut sagt nummer zwei
des rest vielleicht mit einem jungen den
du ganz cool findest und deine beste
freundin hat dir so ein richtiges
geheimnis erzählt wo du dachtest du das
ist schon krass und weil du irgendwie
was zum schreiben braucht mit dem jungen
oder weil halt in cool findest und ihr
irgendwie darauf kommt erzählst du genau
dieses geheimnis weiß was ich meine das
nicht so cool glaube ich
weil ja kummer ihr kennt euch eigentlich
noch gar nicht so lange aber nur weil du
ihn ganz cool findet verrätst du dich du
hast einfach kein profilbild das soll
jetzt gar nicht schlecht sein weil du
vielleicht einfach keine lust fasten
profilbild zu machen will ich auch gar
kein raten wenn ihr das ich möchte dann
ist das vollkommen ok nur wenn du dann
vielleicht mit einer person schreibst
die eigentlich ganz cool findet die
denkt dann vielleicht du hast sie gar
nicht eingespeichert genauer termin
das kann er passiert weil bei mir ist es
zum beispiel so alle personen die ich
nicht ein gespeichert habe können mein
profil mit nicht sehen
mein status glaube ich schon und dass
wir dann auch sinn ergeben also dann
sagt vielleicht bescheid so jo ich habe
kein profilbild mach dir keinen kopf ich
hab dich schon eingespeichert als susan
boyle nein es sollte man auch nicht
schreiben aber das wissen eigentlich
alle wir machen weiter mit punkt keine
ahnung wie viel auf jeden fall pennies
[Musik]
wenn du so setzte kriegst du einfach so
ein paar wörter fehlt so so voller sie
mäßig also schreibt doch einfach normal
deutsch wo ich mein das kann eigentlich
jeder jetzt nichts gegen die leute die
vielleicht noch nicht so gut deutsch
können weil sie nicht so lange in
deutschland wohnen oder sonst was aber
wenn ihr es könnt dann schreibt da nicht
so ein satz wie jetzt wirklich keine
enden heute deutsch erste stunde ich
fick lehrerin wolle das ist voll eklig
so lehrerin war ja und das waren jetzt
sechs punkte glaube ich und ich dachte
mir fallen vielmehr ein aber gerade vor
allem irgendwie keine ahnung hast du ich
hab noch was gefunden ein junge fragt
hast du vielleicht so coole bilder von
dir auf dem handy nein schickt ihm kein
bild das nicht gut
auf keinen fall doch ich habe die idee
wenn er fragt hast ein cooles bild von
dir auch wenn die ein cooles bild schick
einfach im bild wodurch skateboard fest
weil es ja cool
war ich weiß gar nicht wie lang das
widget heute ist so hast du noch was
wenn ihr euch über youtube deutschland
unterhalte und vielleicht wäre eure
lieblings youtuber sind schreibt als
mädchen nicht so mein lieblings youtube
als alex wie weil das kommt durch nicht
so gut ich mein wetter dann auf youtube
gehen sollte und mich anschauen würde
wird er euch vielleicht nicht mehr
antworten aber wer weiß ich bin gut
drauf so ich weiß nicht warum aber
wollte ich euch einfach mal sagen ja ich
glaube das war eines meiner kürzesten
videos ich wollte mich nur eigentlich
mal mit diesem video krass bei euch
bedanken in letzter zeit es ist wirklich
so heftig ich habe jetzt in den letzten
tagen wieder so viel erleben dürfen dank
euch das war wirklich alles so cool und
danke auch für den krassen support wir
haben jetzt den letzten 30 tagen schon
wieder so viele kasse videos gehabt die
wo so ein krasses feedback draufgekommen
ist das hätte ich irgendwie mir niemals
erträumt können und wir haben halt
500.000 so dass das richtig krass weil
ich einfach mal sagen ja keine ahnung
danke dafür und jetzt abonniert mich
alle über instagram danke leute ihr
könnt in die kommentare schreiben
was bei euch so die größten fehler waren
die ihm beim chatten auf whatsapp oder
sonstwo gemacht habt das lese ich mir
dann mal durch können gelder nach oben
da lassen und danke für alles wir sehen
uns sonntag wieder da kommt ein neues
cooles video und freut euch auf jeden
fall auf nächste woche
weil da kommen richtigkeit dieses also
nächste woche kommen 45 videos die
werden aber da dürft ihr auf keinen fall
verpassen
da dürft ihr auf keinen fall verpassen
dadurch dir auf keinen fall 1 verpassen
irgendwie macht dass beides kann sind
wir sehen uns hart rein